in front of your bar in San Diego you're
being your bouncer
right sure and and imagine how many how
many windows and doorways can you see
yeah thousands yeah
it might be thousands right it's more
than it's possible like maybe tenth
given yeah like ten thousand because the
angles it may not be
it's not infinite but there is a really
hard a very large number because because
it's not just the building across the
street or the next building down or the
next it's like six buildings down more
than that it's every building you can
see every building you can see yeah and
the rooftop and the windows so we now
imagine
that the previous day when you were
doing your bouncing job
you were standing out there with your
friend Fred and all of a sudden Fred's
head just disappeared
and now it's now it's the next day and
you're going to work how do you feel